protection maternelle et infantile voilà
ce qui se cache derrière la pmi le
département des yvelines compte 23
centres de pmi pour pratiquer cette
médecine préventive
elle visait à s'assurer de la bonne
santé de l'enfant au sein de son
environnement et de sa famille ici au
centre de conflans sainte honorine les
consultations sont réalisés en équipe
l'assistante qui accueille les familles
l'infirmière puéricultrice qui fait une
consultation de puériculture avec les
les mensurations les rythmes des enfants
le sommeil l'alimentation et en
troisième lieu il ya le médecin dont qui
fait une consultation très complète sur
le plan clinique et psychomoteur pour re
voir comment évolue évoluent les enfants
donc cesser long des consultations plus
longue pour prendre le temps avec les
enfants
elles permettent de mettre en évidence
d'éventuelles difficultés en pmi par
rapport à la médecine de ville on a le
temps on peut vraiment
en ville on a 15 à 20 minutes de
consultation alors qu'ici on peut
facilement prendre le double de temps
on apprécie vraiment l'enfant dans sa
globalité les centres de pmi sont
accessibles gratuitement pour les suivis
de grossesse mais aussi pour le suivi
des enfants de 0 à 6 ans j'ai travaillé
pendant un certain moment où apparemment
dans la filière sociale et pour moi
c'était une suite logique quand mon
premier enfant est né
l'évolution de l'enfant en tout cas est
bien à répertorier et on peut s'assurer
qu'il y ait pas de partir de difficultés
particulières
chaque année dans les yvelines plus de
40 mille consultations médicales sont
réalisés par près de 300 professionnels
de la pmi